Uh,
like to refresh your memory by going back to talk briefly about,
uh,
the two classes last week on fog node and we looked at thoughtless remark,
um,
add the Gona seminar in Japan when he claim that the sound,
the theory is the same story told four times.
So in light of that claim,
we looked at the relation between Benji and Quentin as a relation of kinship and
variation.
The two of them are obviously brothers,
but they can also be seen as brothers in more than just a biological sense.
So this thing about,
um,
kinship and variation as the most fundamental structure of the sound,
the theory,
um,
and so far what we can see is that this structure of kin ship and variation is
pivoted on some kind of battle with time.
As we know Benji,
once caddie never to grow up,
he wants her always to be an innocent young girl,
never to become a woman.
He wants her always to smell like trees.
There's the signature line from Benji.
Um,
in many ways it is a battle for an impossible,
unchanging in lessons.
Um,
and we know that the nature of the battle is such that Benji is destined to be a
loser.
There's no way he can win that battle.
But we also know that the very fact that this is an impossible battle,
that Benji is destined to be a loser also means that it's going to be a
narrative challenge for father.
He has to do something for the loser.
If you are good on there,
you want to do something for the loser.
And so one of the challenges for Faulkner in the sound of the fury is to do
something for Benji.
If we turn to Quentin with the pretty much the same pattern,
repeated the same battle we're time Quentin is exactly like Benji and that he
also wants,
but Kelly and there was a grow up.
He wants to always to be innocent young girl and was to become a grown woman
with her own sexuality.
Um,
and so in that way,
so almost completed with play of that impossible demand from Benji.
But Quentin has an additional battle with time of more abstract battle.
And we see that in the opening of the Quentin section,
he takes out his watch,
he's smashes the crystal,
um,
and then he takes out,
he twists off the hands of the watch.
But we also know any injures his hand in the process.
Um,
so right to them we know that,
you know,
is a losing battle for him to,
uh,
but he twist off the hands of the watch and the watch takes on,
um,
that's a little logo allegory for the entire cause of Quentin section.
So at the end of Clinton section,
we know that the most offending would and that he caused the status would or is
the word temporary.
Um,
and by temporary,
here's one particular context in my,
uh,
his strategy as we are seeing as basically a secondhand tragedy is gone.
His own tragedy,
it is the second hand tragedy of Patty losing her virginity,
but Quentin is embracing it as his own pageant,
um,
and is basically finishing,
uh,
wrapping up his life as response to that tragedy.
But the fear is that that tragedy is going to pass.
That's not going to be a permanent tragedy for him.
Everything is temporary,
even the sense of devastation will go away.
So because temporary is the center's words or the only way,
uh,
Quentin can get around that word is to have a preemptive strike against that
would his suicide is a preemptive strike against the word
temporary so that it will have an artificial permanence in his own life because
his life has ended at that moment and there's no possibility for it to fade
away,
to become less devastating.
Um,
so,
um,
in those ways,
Benji and Quentin and very much brothers in the spiritual sense,
um,
uh,
kind of metaphoric battle with time today,
we'll move on to Jason.
Um,
and it's a bigger challenge,
you know,
to think of Jason as the brother to Quentin and [inaudible].
Jason seems very,
very different on the face of it,
but I like to,
uh,
suggest that in at least one way,
Jason can be seen as a brother to Benji and Quentin.
Um,
in that he also has his own battle with time and is,
it is a battle with a larger,
a constellation of forces.
So we're saying scale and lodgement,
um,
in a very significant way.
In the Jason Section,
uh,
we're seeing a much bigger picture of the United States and best scale
enlargement,
um,
has to do with a tug of war between the yesterday of the United States and to
morrow of the United States.
And Jason wanting very much to cling to the yesterday.
It is more congenial to him in every way,
but at the same time he know that the tomorrow is already here.
In fact that tomorrow is encroaching on the present.
There's nothing he can do about it.
He just has to learn to cope with that tomorrow.
Very uncongenial,
very threatening tomorrow.
He has to learn to come to terms with that.
So the basic dynamic of Jason Section is the battle between yesterday and
tomorrow.
And I think that we know that it pretty much is a losing battle for Jason as
well.
Um,
because we're talking so much about yesterday and tomorrow,
I wanted to bring back that very important passage from Macbeth at five scene
five that thought in the,
took the phrase,
the sound of the fury from tomorrow and tomorrow and tomorrow creeps in this
petty pace from day to day to the last syllable of recorded time.
And a lot of yesterdays have lighters.
The way to does take that it is a tale told by an idiot fury signifying nothing.
So father is really getting the maximum mileage from that passage is really
taking off the entire scaffolding of his novel from the Shakespeare passage.
Um,
and I like to give you a brief overview of the basic structure of today's
lecture.
Um,
the,
the various terms that come into play in this tug of war between yesterday and
tomorrow.
We know that the Horse,
um,
is,
uh,
is actually still a present,
um,
in the sound of the fury.
Queenie,
uh,
the hose,
we'll have a starring row at the very end of the novel.
We don't see her quite in the full yet,
but I promise you should have a starring role.
Um,
we know that all the Movio is very much here.
and I like to think of those,
the horse and the automobile,
um,
as a two directional arrows.
So that course is a vector is a direction directional arrow pointing back to the
19th century.
The very agent,
he'll well where to own a horse,
uh,
mixed you pilot the gen trade as well.
Civility,
uh,
of um,
social distinctions.
Uh,
the automobile is we already have seen in a gas bay,
um,
is a vehicle that to some extent bricks down or complicated social distinctions.
Uh,
it also brings in strangers.
So,
um,
the phrase that I would like to use to think about that kind of transition,
uh,
from the past to the,
um,
is the concept that I'm taking from the literary and cultural critic,
Raymond willingness to notion of the knowable community.
Um,
and how that's receding into the past.
That's breaking down to be replaced by an unknowable world of strangers.
And on that basis I'll talk,
uh,
talk about,
the basic structure really and Jason Section is to patterns of grievances to
patterns of injury.
As we know,
Jason is someone who feels aggrieved all the time.
He hit the,
that the whole world has done him and,
and pod in the boat wrong.
Um,
so he's complaining all the time.
That's his mode.
Uh,
but given that this is the baseline for Jason,
he has two different,
um,
Polly's,
two different kinds of people,
uh,
that he's complaining about.
Uh,
one is the gnome Polly's people in his immediate environment,
people he knows very well.
Um,
and then they are total strangers who also doing him around the,
he knows nothing about,
but he's convinced a out together.
Um,
so the notion that they are strangers somewhere to get you versus people right
here who do,
doing your in right on the spot.
Um,
and so,
um,
the people who are right there as family,
you've his servants,
his father,
his niece,
Quentin,
um,
and the unknown parties including the usual suspects,
New York Jew,
US government,
Western Union,
Telegraph,
and of course wall straight.
Um,
so very familiar,
getting very close to us actually.
Um,
but,
um,
this is the image,
that I find,
uh,
in some sense are kind of a capsule summary of the dynamics.
In the Jason Section.
You see the horse and caught the 19th century relic.
Um,
and then the automobile,
uh,
right coming,
right.
I'm almost going to run it over.
We fear.
Um,
and that's the situation that we get in,
uh,
the sound beginning in the Jason Session.
Um,
we know that Jason,
um,
actually is part of the future is probably tomorrow,
in the sense that he owns the car and he's very proud.
He's seen in his car a lot and he's very proud that his is a relatively
expensive cost,
not as,
and he makes a point that,
you know,
the people who own for us,
but his car is for,
we don't know what kind of car he has,
but,
uh,
is a call he is proud of.
Uh,
and he spends a little time in,
but there's a basic in compatibility between Jason,
um,
and his car.
And this comes back to the comps and Corrs,
uh,
it turns out that Jason's faculty or smell is as highly developed as his two
brothers.
In his case,
the smell,
the guests to him isn't this now trees,
the smell of honeysuckle,
but the smell of gasoline you can stand,
there's a smell of gasoline.
It gives them a tremendous headache.
The only time he only way he can drive is by putting a handkerchief.
So in cancer over his nose,
that's only what you can drive his own car.
So,
um,
this is,
his,
um,
complain about this vehicle,
uh,
that belongs to him.
He wouldn't dream of getting rid of,
but it's a burden to him.
And now I reckon I'll get home just in time to take a nice long drive after a
basket of tomatoes or something and then have to go back to Tom smelling like a
cancer,
the factory.
So my head will explode right on my shoulders.
I said,
you don't know where the headache is.
I says,
you think a food at them,
Carla,
if it depended on me,
of course he's complaining.
That is not by choice that he's in this car.
But we also know that,
you know,
he's proud of his car.
So this is just to lay out basic difficulty in Jason situation is that there's
attention,
a conflict between his own physical wellbeing and the most basic ingredient of
an automobile.
Structural in compatibility between Jason is a biological human being and the
mechanical workings of the car.
Uh,
but beyond that there's also something else that makes the automobile a terrible
threat to Jason at,
which is the kinds of people who come with automobiles.
Um,
and uh,
is already we're beginning to see a wall of strangers opening up right there in
Jefferson,
Mississippi.
So here's Jason.
I had just turned onto the street when I saw a thought coming helling to what
made all of a sudden it stopped.
I could hear the wheel sliding and is fluid around and back and world.
And just as I was thinking what the hell they were up to,
I saw the red tie and I recognize her face.
Looking back through the window,
I saw a rat and I recognize that red tie after all I had told her,
I forgot about everything.
I never thought about my head even until I came to the first Fox and had to
stop.
Yet we spend money and spend money on rose and damn,
if it isn't like trying to drive over a sheet of corrugated iron roofing,
I like to know how a man could be expected to keep up with even the wheelbarrow.
Um,
in the space of two paragraphs,
we see that Jason has shifted his attention from his knees,
Quentin,
um,
to the government who's not keeping up the rows.
Right?
So,
right.
The first thing that we can say about this passage is that the word timeframe
isn't just a curse for Quanton.
It is also because for Jason,
he has a very short attention span.
He can really keep his mind fixed on the thing that he's going to complain
against.
Um,
and that's just a little aside.
You know,
it's not something that Jason Himself,
um,
no,
this is,
but we can say that for him is that he really does one strike against them.
Um,
and his battle with time that he is such a short attention span that he can hold
onto what the little time that he has or he can make that time last long and can
make you squeeze Evans last longer.
So not being able to make something last longer is one of the problems with
Jason.
Um,
but the most in,
and that's a long term,
you know,
kind of generic constitutional problems for Jason.
But the most immediate problems for him is that his niece Quentin,
the daughter of Catty,
is running around with Togo strangers.
Um,
and we don't know who this man is.
Uh,
Jason is not telling us because he doesn't know.
Um,
all I can say is that this is a man with a red tie and that tells him that this
man is no good.
Um,
and that quintessentially hanging out with this man wearing a red tie and he
comes with a car that's a relatively,
I don't myself consider for the cheap car,
but Jason considers that achieve current.
Therefore there's another strike against the stranger that he's no good.
Um,
in the next two,
this is on page two 38 two.
Next page.
We know who this stranger is,
not really what kind of a person he is,
but what kind of occupation he has.
I said as far as I'm concerned,
the other girl to hell as fast as she pleases.
And the sooner the better as,
as what else do you expect?
Except every damn tromping around and cheap show that comes to town because even
those towns jellybeans give her the go by now.
And that shows how far the comms and fortune has fallen from being the town.
Gentry.
Um,
Quentin has fallen so low that even the town jelly beans touch her.
the only way she can have some company is to hang out with strangers coming to
town for the first time.
Um,
cheap shows.
It's confusing to see the drummer in the context of the chief show.
You know,
we might think that the drummer is someone who plays the drums,
but actually,
no,
this is a specialized 19th century,
late 19th century turn of the century,
early 20th century,
a slang word for the traveling salesman.
Um,
so Jason is using that theory,
distinct period,
uh,
usage,
the drama.
This is a traveling salesman.
We know that he's going to be there,
you know,
punished with day,
uh,
to keep Quentin comedy and then he'll be gone.
Um,
so,
um,
Jason in that way is,
uh,
an entry point for us,
to that 19th century world.
Uh,
the changing well of salesmanship of marketing.
That's very important that we have traveling salesman who drive around in cars.
Um,
fast living,
traveling salesman,
all those are so new developments.
Um,
and um,
the other thing we can say about this drummer,
um,
is that he's known to Jason to the extent that he is normally law.
Um,
primarily because of two attributes.
One is,
is the most thing that stands out from him is the fact that he's wearing a red
tie.
That's a giveaway for Jason.
And the other thing is that his occupation is written on his face.
The fact that he's a traveling salesman is um,
clear just from anyone can see that that's what he is.
So Jason's knowledge after drama doesn't extend food and that it is a very
superficial knowledge,
um,
of this man.
Not because Jason doesn't want to know him.
Well,
maybe just it doesn't,
uh,
in any case,
that knowledge will never extend further than the color of his tie and
occupational label that Jason can pin on him.
Um,
it is a world that is by definition made up of our superficial knowledge of
total strangers.
People we see once and never again.
That is the world that is opening up in front of Jason.
Um,
we can decide whether or not this is a world that we like or not.
we have no choice.
I think that this is also the world of who we are.
And quite often,
most of the people that we need actually our people we see once and never again,
um,
that we know just by those two attributes,
what kind of clothes they wear.
A and w surmises as to what my occupation is they have.
So,
um,
Jason is,
tomorrow is in many ways our present.
And here I want to um,
um,
in to mention the work of one of my heroes really,
uh,
Raymond Williams,
very,
um,
influential literary and cultural critic.
Um,
he died some time ago,
um,
and um,
his classic work,
the country and the city.
Um,
in that work,
uh,
Raymond Williams coins the phrase a knowable communities and find one of the
chapters of the book is called knowable communities.
And this is what Raymond Williams has
a country community.
Most typically a village is an epitome of direct relationships of face to face
context within which we can find and value the substance of personal
relationships as the scale and complexity of the characteristics.
Social organizations increase a whole community,
holy,
knowable becomes harder and harder to sustain.
So Raymond Willingness,
his idea is that modernity is defined by the breakdown of that unsustainable
utopian,
ideal,
knowable communities.
Um,
and uh,
he really reads,
uh,
almost off.
He was English.
Um,
so he reads almost all English literature using that concept art.
And I'm extending his insight,
um,
to American literature.
And here I want to start very briefly and say a word about plagiarism.
I know that,
uh,
the first paper is coming up for you guys.
Um,
and I just want to emphasize how important it is to acknowledge where you are
getting your ideas from,
where you're getting your wording from.
Knowable community is a phrase that I could've made up myself.
Um,
but it is really important to acknowledge the book that you,
or the article that you got the,
the,
the concept from very,
very important for two reasons.
One is that it is just occur to say needed recognition to the person who came up
with the idea.
Um,
if you were to come up with a great phrase,
you want people to acknowledge you.
Um,
but I think that more than that,
um,
I think that citation or practices are not just a technicality and not just a
way to get was house.
Our trouble is a way to show that we're in dialogue with some one else.
Um,
and because Raymond Williams is such a hero for me,
um,
I actually take a lot of pleasure,
in thinking that,
you know,
even though he,
he didn't write about Faulkner,
um,
that actually is insights at the lie.
So well to follow her.
So it is the pleasure of having a long and extended,
uh,
conversation,
with someone you know,
with people that you admire,
who's work you enjoy reading.
Um,
so for both those two reasons,
um,
is pleased and knowledge where you're getting your ideas from.
So I'm using Raymond Williams's idea of the knowable community.
Um,
I want to,
um,
think about,
Jason's a structure of injury,
his pattern of injury,
um,
and are we looking at two passages that suggest that he's still in a knowable
community and then we'll move on to that much more pressing.
Uh,
the world is going to win out in the world that is made up of unknowable
strangers,
but close,
um,
knowable community based on Jefferson,
Massachusetts.
This is Jason.
That breakfast once the bitch always a bitch,
when I say I say us,
you're lucky if a plane I was at school is all that.
Whereas you,
I says she ought to be done here,
down there in that kitchen right now is the up there in a room gobbing paint on
her face and waiting for six niggers.
They can't even stand up out of a chair unless they got a pan full bread and
meat to balance them to fix breakfast for her.
So the basic problem,
one of the basic problems for Jason that we know there's earlier,
the very short attention span is very much in evidence here.
He starts off complaining against his knees,
Quentin,
by the end of that hazard,
she's complaining about the niggers in his household.
Um,
so he can hold on to a grievance for very long to wear temporaries.
Definitely a course they have.
Um,
but even though the word temporary is a curse for Jason,
he actually aspires to permanence.
And we see that in the opening line of that passage once that bitch always a
bit,
it is not a proverb.
There's no such profit,
uh,
you know,
the well,
but it has the feel of a problem.
It has the feel of a province like permanence and this is the small town,
Jason who is speaking,
um,
finding enormous satisfaction from making pronouncements that sound like
proverbs.
This is his take on and he is able to sum up the entire world.
Uh,
just using,
um,
seven words.
You can really do better than that,
a seven worst summation of the entire world.
So just enormous satisfaction.
So we can say that even though Jason is complaining nonstop,
even though that's his nose,
um,
this is one instance where complaining,
it's actually a very pleasurable activity for Jason.
He's getting a kick,
being able to say that his knees was a bitch and she will always be one.
Um,
and he's getting a kick out of talking about the thickness of her makeup.
and everything that is objectionable about her gifts,
him enormous pleasure.
So complaining in,
oh no.
In a world of numb at quantities and
Quinten is very much a known quantity to Jason complaining about people right
around you.
If you people in your immediate family,
that's a really fun thing to do.
And Jason is having fun doing that.
He's having fun complaining about the black servants.
Um,
and in his mind as far as he's concerned,
Quentin,
his knees and those blacks ovens I exactly alike.
They're all good for nothing.
They are all a trial for him.
They all wronging him in some fashion.
They a grain on his financial resources brain on his patients.
Um,
it's just a burden that he has to carry through life that he happens to have in
these like that and sermons like that.
He can go on and on.
Um,
he can go on all day like this.
and it would be a very happy life for him to be able to go on like that.
So this is the pleasure that one gets from a knowable community.
Um,
and I'll just give you another instance of that.
I'm very much in the same vein.
Like I say,
if he had to sell something to San Quentin,
to Harvard,
we're all ban a damn sight better off if you,
so that sideboard and bought himself a one arm straight jacket with part of the
money.
I reckon the reason all the Compson gave out before it got to me like mother
says,
is that he drank it up,
at least I never heard of him offering to sell anything to send me to Harvard.
Um,
so two complaints here,
both center on his father,
Mr. Thompson.
One is that his father drinks and that the uh,
in fact that it is true that the Sam,
one of the many punctuate punctuation marks,
um,
metaphoric punctuation marks in the sound of the fury and Mr. Thompson mucking
the trips to the sideboard to get the bruise.
Um,
that's one of the punctuation marks in the sound of the theory.
So Jason isn't wrong that his father drinks and how they squandering away the
whole comms and fortune to the extent that there is one now he's squandering
away the whole fortune by drinking.
So,
um,
Jason,
Susan has a kind of legitimate complaint,
um,
but the deeper complain,
that goes along with the fact that his father trains is that Quentin,
his brother was his father's favorite.
Um,
that his father,
um,
as much as he loves drinking,
he probably love,
loved Quentin better.
I love alcohol.
Um,
and he would go so far as to sell the pastures Benji's polishes so that Quentin
would go to Harvard.
Of course he killed himself off the one year,
so all the money was wasted.
Um,
and that is just even more grounds for complain for Jason.
Uh,
one that's again,
I have to say it's fairly understandable grievance.
Um,
the sense of not being loved,
the sense that nobody has ever done anything for him,
that everything that could be done in that family was being done for Quentin and
then who wasted everything.
Um,
is,
it's an almost,
I wouldn't say it's a completely legitimate grievance.
There's a very understandable as a of why he's someone that nobody things about.
Nobody ever gives a thought to the wellbeing of Jason.
Um,
and what kinds of,
or do you get,
you know,
when nobody ever gives them thought of his wellbeing.
Um,
so he's in any ways Faulkner,
and I'm just preparing you for the ending of the sound and fury.
Where do you think that even though Jason is loser,
um,
once again,
often the dust or something for that loser.
He's a very sad loser.
And here we see some of the reason for that sadness is that people turn into
monsters when they feel that they are completely unloved.
Um,
and uh,
but still right now along with the south today along with the constant
complaining,
Jason is getting some satisfaction from the fact that he's complaining against
his father once again,
no on a day to him,
uh,
all know all too well in this,
in this instance.
So less look at,
um,
the breakdown of that knowable well,
because it's satisfying to Jason,
that's the thing that's going to be taken away from him.
Um,
so the last thing that gives him set aside,
it gives him satisfaction is going to be taken away from him.
And the breakdown of the knowable community,
um,
comes with automobile.
Um,
as we have seen,
um,
and all those things the serve,
intimated by the arrival of the automobile,
The New York Jew,
US government,
Western Union,
Wall Street.
Um,
so let's look at one instance of Jason stance that he's wronged by unknown
parties.
And um,
all of a sudden we see that the world has expanded tremendously.
That even though Jason is still in Jefferson,
Mississippi,
that all of a sudden New York City becomes his horizon,
becomes his reference point.
I don't see how a city,
no bigger than New York can hoe enough people to take the money away from us
countries suckers.
Well,
I'm done with them.
They sent me in for the last time any full except the fellow that hasn't got any
more sense than to take a juice worth for anything could tell the market was
going up all the time,
the whole Damn Delta about with let it again and the cotton,
the wash right out of the ground like it was last year that they wash them as
crop out of the ground year after year and them up there in Washington spending
$50,000 a year keeping an army in Nicaragua or sounds ways,
incredible scale enlargement in the world.
Jason,
not only in New York City,
but Central America as well.
So we have to figure out why it is that the world suddenly opening up in this
drastic fashion.
Um,
and it turns out that actually closer to home,
um,
this actually,
Jewish populations that they've can,
Jewish populations,
Jewish community and Clarksville,
Mississippi.
So Jason could have seen these people.
He goes to socialize with his Jewish neighbors,
but he's not thinking about his Jewish neighbors.
Um,
he also,
because he's talking about New York City,
he also could have been talking about a lower east side and has the street,
and this is a picture of Hester Street,
uh,
turn of the century.
Um,
these are not very threatening people.
Jason could have been talking about dose Jews.
Uh,
those New York Jews.
He's not thinking about the dose instead.
Um,
the noodles you,
that he has in mind,
um,
is very similar.
It's kind of a transnational to,
uh,
this is a picture by the French painter.
They go,
we,
I think that we know him,
a pelly from [inaudible] paintings of the,
uh,
ballet dancers.
So,
you know,
we think of him as a painter,
very graceful bodies emotion,
but,
um,
he asked,
Ashley also has a whole range of paintings about social portraits.
Um,
and this is a painting of a Jewish French Jewish banker at the fringe tools,
um,
stock exchange in Paris.
Um,
and the kind of the machinations,
um,
engaged in by the,
the proverbial,
uh,
I Guess Transnational Ju,
always scheming and conspiring,
um,
for new good.
Um,
Jason's image of the New York Jew has everything in common with this antisemetic
image and they guy was painting.
And,
um,
so we can see that,
you know,
is really the whole financial world is really opening up in the Jason Section.
But there's one other detail that we get in,
in this.
Jason is also a guy for us,
uh,
to the world of the 19th 20th,
basically the whole of the early 20th century,
uh,
because he's mentioned to Nicaragua and it turns out that that's actually an
accurate,
accurate mansion.
The United States was in Nicaragua and from 1909 to 1933,
uh,
the,
in 1916 getting closer to the date of the sound of the fury,
that sound of the fury,
let me just say,
was published in 1929.
Okay,
so keep that date in your mind.
1929,
but in any case,
in 1916,
uh,
there was the Chamorro Ryan Treaty.
Uh,
it was ratified by the US Senate in 1916 and it gave the United States exclusive
rights to build an inter oceanic and now across Nicaragua.
Um,
the Panama Canal was ready in existence,
but there was some thought that maybe another can now might be useful.
Um,
and the United States was claiming exclusive rights to build a canal.
and that treaty also turn Nicaragua in two a near US protect,
right?
So that's,
Jason's complained about the $50,000 that we did,
uh,
spend to keep an army and Nicaragua.
So,
um,
Jason was someone who reached the newspapers.
Clearly he's a good newspaper readers.
It's up on the news.
He has almost legitimate complaints against the US government and the foreign
intervention of the u s government and the brain,
um,
on the finances of the United States.
Um,
and um,
so the,
all of a sudden there's a conflation of the New York Jews,
the US government strangers,
um,
at a distance up to no good,
right?
So you know,
people who are far away,
you never set sight on them.
Um,
they are harming you in some fashion.
Last look at,
um,
another way in which,
uh,
in the here in,
in the earlier,
um,
passage when the US government has just spending $50,000 the day and they go,
Robert,
um,
Jason himself claims to be completely innocent.
He's just harmed by the policy of foreign policy of the United States
government.
But in the next passage,
uh,
we see that actually,
Jason is in some sense a willing party,
uh,
to,
um,
the harm that is coming to him in a sense that he is competitors,
uh,
in the world he is complaining about.
Um,
and this is also,
uh,
the second instance of injury from um,
a nobodies damn.
If I believe anybody knows anything about a damn thing except the ones that sit
back and those New York offices and watch the country's sufferers come up and
begged them to take the money.
Only you dead.
If it doesn't look like a company as big and rich as western union to get a
market report out on time,
half as quick as they'll get a wire to you saying,
you account closed out the,
what the hell do they care about?
People,
they're hand in glove with the New York crowd and could see that.
Why is Jason so obsess with the Western Union and with the Telegraph as the new
we develop instrumentality of communication.
Well,
it turns out that he's a smart investor and he wants to find out exactly how
it's also doing,
if he wants to go to invest or withdrawal as money.
Uh,
so the Western Union is crucially is relation to Wall Street is we show,
but the western union is crucial in getting those reports to him on time and
allowing him to change his investments in time.
And it turns out that the western union was in fact very common.
The site in the south,
they were many telegraph officers in the south.
And this is the main office,
the Western Union office in New York City.
Um,
so once again,
Jason really knows what he's talking about.
He's naming,
um,
entities that actually was real historical entities.
Um,
and um,
and he is a bank.
This is a historic and on the historic Oxford Square,
um,
in,
uh,
Oxford,
Mississippi.
That is Jefferson as a civic.
Um,
and,
uh,
with this writer,
this is the main square in town.
So bands,
we're also a very important presence,
um,
in Oxford,
Mississippi and um,
is really Jason's,
um,
relationship to the banks,
both the local banks.
And I'll show the national banks on Wall Street by way of the mediated by the
Western Union.
Um,
that really is the main relation in his life.
yes,
he has a relation to his knees.
Clinton is a religion to his mother.
Yes,
relation.
There's black servants.
He hates them all.
Um,
and the most significant relation that he has is to his money help,
uh,
in Jabuti now,
by the national banks in wall on Wall Street.
Um,
so,
um,
and it is in that context that all of a sudden the proverb life phase phrase
reappears.
Uh,
but in a very sad,
almost have to be from Jason and Jason.
Like I say,
once the bitch always a bitch and just let me have 24 hours without any Damn New
York Jew to advise me what is going to do.
I don't want to make a killing saved that the suck in this muck canvas with,
I just want an even chance to get my money back.
I think that that is the very small hole on the bottom of Jason.
He's not asking to make a huge sum of money.
He just doesn't want to lose all his money.
Um,
and it's such a model is hope that we know is bound to be defeated because of
course in such a world of long distance action,
um,
and we'll operate it by total strangers with huge,
large scale impose no institutions.
Small investors are the ones who lose out.
Um,
so,
you know,
it's a phenomenon that we recognize very well.
Um,
in that way,
I think that we shouldn't forget that just as Faulkner has a lot of sympathy for
Benji,
Faulkner also has a lot less than the day for Jason.
It's very hard for us as readers to have any sympathy for Jason at all.
He's just such an offensive of putting kind of character.
Um,
but I think that that very resonant,
um,
small,
I just wanted an even chance to get my money back.
Um,
in two in that one phrase,
Jason in many ways speaks for all of us.
Uh,
and thought the knows that,
um,
that's it is that is in many ways the most important phrase and the Jason
Section.
Um,
and as it turns out,
the irony of history is such that the history of the United States turn out to
be a corridor to the sound and the fury because the same year that the sound of
the fury came out was also the year of the crash.
And here is an image of the trading floor of the New York Stock Exchange.
Um,
and two more images.
The crowds outside the New York Stock Exchange.
Um,
all those people are probably much bigger investors than Jason.
They're right there on the spot.
They probably big investors or stop there.
You know,
their,
their trailer is actually,
a lot of them were trailers,
so they were insiders,
uh,
on Wall Street.
But even the insiders had the illusory sense that if you could just be there
physically,
that that would make a difference.
So this proves that Raymond Williams's idea of to knowable community,
it's actually a psychological demand from all of us.
All of us want to know the people we are having transactions with.
All of us are creating their work,
knowable communities right around us,
even though the actual historical circumstances are making dose,
knowable communities and impossible idea in the present.
So we know that those people are there on the spot trying to recreate in vain
and Utopian ideal from the past.
And even though they are not countries suckers like Jason,
um,
in the sense that they are not from Mississippi,
they resemble him in more ways than one.
So in that sense,
the Jason Section represents the largest possible scale for,
uh,
thoughts on her.
Uh,
it really is about the Taiwan capture,
uh,
by Jason's dealing news,
and his failed attempt to come to terms of the future.
To tomorrow that he's guiding us to is really no place to be.
But I think this is for him and for lots of other people that yes,
the present.
Um,
but,
uh,
for Jason is the problem of trying to find a resting phase,
the sustainable or some kind of bearable plays in that tomorrow,
that's going to be the challenge for Faulkner in the last section of the sound,
the theory.
So we'll come back,
um,
to,
uh,
an alternative to the automobile at the very end of the sound of the fury.
And Jason's a satisfaction to that.